Few years ago, a wave of Vitamin A deficiency
hit many parts of the globe.
The deficiency was so severe that it resulted
in several deaths within no time!
What could have been done to crack this problem?
Scientists soon realised that the staple food
of most of the areas hit by this disaster
was Rice.
They took efforts to modify rice in such a
way that it produced the necessary compound
in the body when consumed.
With this, the concept of Golden rice emerged!
It’s a variety of rice that is capable of
biosynthesizing beta-carotene which is a precursor
of vitamin A. When consumed, the beta-carotene
is readily converted to Vitamin A in the body,
thus saving uncountable lives!
Doesn’t this sound like science fiction?
It definitely does, but this has actually happened!
Let me make it more interesting!
Imagine there is one single plant that has
potatoes in the root and tomatoes at the shoot!
Do you think this is possible?
Of course it is!
This variety is called Pomato: a plant that
bears 2 edible parts in the same body!
And now for the last one!
Imagine you’re in a dark room and suddenly
you find a fluorescently glowing mice running
around!
Do you think this kind of glowing mice exist?
Yes they do!
The concept of fluorescent mice is no longer
fiction because there are transgenic mice
which glow with fluorescence!
Why are we looking at these examples?
We know that Computers run on codes, and so
do our bodies!
Just like there are specific codes for running
a computer, we have specific codes for organisms’
body design.
And any change in these codes, can give us
miraculous results like the golden rice, the
Pomato plant and the glowing mice!
And the study of all these wonderful concepts
is nothing but “GENETICS”!
We have come across this term several times!
Genetics finds applications not only in modern
day research but even answers various queries
that pop up in our minds.
Many of us assume that genetics is only about the
characters passed on to children from their
parents, but is it as simple as that?
And even if we know or assume things, it is
important to ask the question ‘Why’.
For instance, have you ever wondered why an
apple tree only gives rise to another apple tree?
Why don’t we get a banana or a mango tree from it?
Why does a cat gives birth to only a kitten?
And why do humans give birth to humans only?
Well you may say, that the answer is nature!
Okay!
So now can you tell me that if a human gives
birth to another human, then why are those
two not exactly the same?
Why do we find each individual unique?
What makes the kid strikingly different from
his or her parents?
Well, there are endless questions that pop
up in our minds.
And how do we find answers to them?
That's where the branch of “Genetics ” comes into play.
In this lesson, and in the upcoming one's, let's
get introduced to this branch and try answering
all the questions that pop-up in our minds
about the living world around us!
To begin with, let's define Genetics.
In simple terms, it can be defined as the
branch of Biology that deals with heredity
and genetic variation .
Now you may wonder what do these two terms mean?
To begin our studies on genetics, we
need to first understand a few terms in detail.
Let us begin with understanding what heredity is!
Let’s assume this is one happy family . Now
if we observe this kid, he has a few features
like his dad and a few like his mom!
That is because he has got these features
from each parent.
This passing of traits or characters from
one generation to the other is nothing but heredity!
So we can define heredity as passing of traits
from parents to their offsprings.
Now what do we exactly mean by Traits and characters?
It’s simple!
In this case , the child has black coloured
eyes just like his mom.
The father however has blue coloured eyes.
Now here we have two different types of eye
colours, black and blue.
Similarly, there are many other colours of
eyes that exist in nature.
So the eye colour is the character.
The eye colour can vary among the population of a
particular species.
On the other hand, trait will be black or
blue colour of the eyes, which is exclusive
for that particular individual.
To take another example, height is a character,
while tall and short are the traits.
Hair colour is a character, while black and
blonde are the traits.
So the passing of these traits from one generation
to the other is called heredity . And what
has got passed to the next generation is usually
referred to as Inheritance!
Now tell me one thing.
If this boy has inherited the traits from
his parents, why is he not the exact copy
of either of the parent?
I mean why does he look slightly different from both?
The answer lies in the single term called “variation”.
Isn’t the term self-explanatory?
As the name says, it means differences.
So variations are the differences that make
one organism different from its parents.
As in this case, the boy has inherited a few
traits from his mom and a few from his dad.
But he is different from both!
Thus, there are many variations in him!
These basics in genetics are known to us now.
But ever wondered who laid the foundations
of this interesting subject?
Who were the pioneers in genetics that helped
us crack the code of life?
Let's have a glance at the history of genetics
in the upcoming part!
This image of evolution is not new to us!
But ever wondered how species evolved?
How are a few factors eliminated and a few
carried forward?
Well, the answers are obtained when we combine
evolutionary studies with genetics!
Many scientists have been working on genetics
since ages.
But there was one legendary figure who could
answer why a green pea plant gave rise to
another similar green pea plant.
Let's get back in time to understand how
the foundations of Genetics were laid!
Genetic studies were carried out since the
classical era wherein scientists like Aristotle
and Hippocrates had put forth a few theories
regarding how parental characters are passed
to the next generation.
However, a breakthrough was achieved when
an Augustinian friar carried out remarkable
experiments using garden pea plants and laid
the foundations of modern day genetics.
It was around the nineteenth century that
Gregor Johan Mendel , now known as the “father
of genetics” performed the experiments that
lead him to this path.
Mendel, while working in a garden wondered
why the green pea plants with one particular
trait gave rise to plants with the same trait…
For example , plants with purple flowers gave
rise to plants with purple flowers only.
So,Why is this so?
And Why do white colour flowered plants give plants
with white colour flowers only?
And what will happen if these two varieties are crossed?
With all these queries in mind, Mendel decided
to carry out a few experiments that would
help him find out the answers.
But where did he think all these experiments
would take him?
How did he think of beginning with the procedures?
And what were the list of requirements he gathered?
What could have been the possible conclusions?
Let us try answering all these questions one by one!
To begin with, let's understand WHY did Gregor
Mendel chose Pisum sativum, commonly known
as the green pea plant.
Mendel knew that for his experiments, he would
require a plant which is perennial and not
annual.
In literal terms, perennial means something
that can last for a long time.
Here it meant the plant than can grow and
reproduce in a recurring fashion.
Secondly, the plant should have a small life cycle.
It should be able to grow quickly.
Also, Mendel wanted a plant that would not
require too many exclusive conditions to grow.
Minimal requirements should suffice
the growth of the plant.
Most importantly, to understand the results
of crossing different varieties better, Mendel
required contrasting traits in the plants.
That means one character should have two contrasting
traits.
For example, the flower colour in green peas
is purple and in some it's white.
Purple and white are the contrasting traits
that can help in the study!
So which were the contrasting characters that
Mendel found in the green pea plants?
There were seven pairs of contrasting characters
in total chosen by Mendel in the plant.
Here they are
The first character Mendel chose was height
of the plant . The contrasting traits were
tall and dwarf plants.
Second character in the list was the colour
of the flower . The contrasting traits were
purple coloured flowers and white coloured flowers.
And the third character on the list was position
of the flower . That could be either axial
or terminal.
In simple words, Axial means the flowers shoot
off from the middle of the stem, and terminal
means that the flower is situated at the top
of the plant stem.
The next character chosen was shape of the seed.
We know that green peas have two types of
seeds.
One type is round and smooth, while the other
type is rough or wrinkled with scales.
This was the next pair of contrasting traits.
After seed shape, we have the character of
seed colour . The contrasting traits in this
are the green and yellow colours of the seeds.
Similar to the seed colour, the next character
was pod colour . A pod is nothing but a case
that holds the plant’s seeds.
Here the two contrasting traits were green
coloured and yellow coloured pods.
And the last pair of contrasting character was
that of pod shape . Green pea pods can either
be inflated or constricted.
Both these traits are contrasting!
With these seven pairs of contrasting characters,
Mendel began his experiments.
Little did he know that he was building the
foundation of modern genetics…
Let's have a look at what his experiments
were and the conclusions he derived from them
in the next part.
We have taken a look at the seven pairs of
contrasting characters chosen by Gregor Mendel
for his experiments on the green pea plant.
so here is a table that gives us an idea of what
the contrasting characters and their respective
traits were !
Now can you guess how Mendel thought of this
experiment?
How was it exactly planned by Mendel?
What was his aim?
Well, Mendel thought of beginning with trying
to understand what happens on crossing the
plants with contrasting traits.
Mendel, just like others, knew that a plant
with purple flowers gives us another plant
with purple flowers only.
And it's the same case with a plant that has white
coloured flowers.
Now Mendel was curious to know, what will
happen if a purple flowered plant is crossed
with the white flowered variety?
Ideally the result has to be flowers with
intermediate colours.
But was that actually what Mendel got?
Let's have a look at the results in detail.
But before that , do you know how crossing
is carried out?
Well, the male and female plants are selected first.
Now the pea plant being bisexual, has both
male and female reproductive parts in the
same plant.
So we can choose the purple flower to be male
and the white flower to be female or vice
versa.
Now the female flower on the respective plant
is emasculated first.
So do you know what emasculation is?
As the name suggests, masculine refers to male.
So here, emasculation refers to the removal
of male reproductive parts.
Let's take these two flowers to understand
the crossing process in detail.
Now the anther of this flower will be removed.
Removal of anthers makes sure that the flower
will not get self-pollinated.
Now this exclusive female flower is dusted
with the pollen grains from this male flower,
which ensures pollination.
And the successful fertilisation will be ensured
when the plant develops flowers!
This is how crossing is carried out!
Now let us get back to Mendel’s experiments.
Mendel crossed a plant with purple flowers
and a plant with white flowers.
He expected results in which the plants obtained
will be intermediate between purple and white.
But to his astonishment, he obtained all the
plants in the progeny to be purple coloured!
Unexpected right?
And this doesn’t stop here!
On crossing the purple coloured flowers from
this progeny with each other, he got another
set of astonishing results!
If purple flowered plants are crossed among
each other, we should obtain which variety?
We would get all plants with purple coloured
flowers, is what most of us would think!
But to his astonishment, Mendel obtained a
few plants with white coloured flowers as
well!
So on an average, he obtained 75% plants with
purple flowers and 25% plants with white flowers.
How could this be possible now?
Let us try and understand these results in
the next part!